i thought on christmas it would be a  great opportunity to show you what i  think is one of the greatest lawyer  jokes of all time and that's  a merry christmas card from your lawyer  whoever wrote this is clearly an  attorney or works with attorneys it's  just  absolutely perfect to show that you're  not guaranteeing that you wish them a  christmas that  the expectations are set with a  reasonable merry christmas and or  festive period including but not limited  to a happy again reasonable new year and  then the best part of all is of course  that  you have to spell out 12 with the number  one and two  because that's just what lawyers do so  congratulations to whoever wrote this  this is one of the greatest lawyer jokes  of all time  and from legal eagle i wish all of you a  merry christmas  and or festive period your mileage may  vary please consult with your attorney